après une vingtaine d'années pendant
lesquelles ces grandes
plateformes se sont retranché se sont
caché derrière les différences de nos
législations de nos réglementations
nationales sacinte liberté d'expression
pour ne pas payer d'impôts et pour
échapper à toutes nos règles et il faut
reconnaître que depuis quelques années
depuis 5 ans les choses ont changé grâce
à la France notamment grâce au président
de la République qui en a fait une une
une cause de de nos de nos batailles
européennes et nous avons en matière
fiscale mis fin à cette situation qui
consistait pour les géants du numérique
à s'installer systématiquement en
Irlande ou parfois au Luxembourg pour
échapper à l'impôt et nous avons mis fin
avec ce règlement le le DSA le Règlement
sur les services numériques qui fait
sortir les grandes plateformes de leur
situation
d'irresponsabilité totale vis-à-vis des
contenus qui transitent sur leurs
interface parce que il y a 20 ans quand
ces plateformes ont émergé la manière
dont elles ont été régulées a consisté à
dire que Facebook Twitter Instagram et
les autres n'ont pas à connaître des
messages qui transitent sur leur service
et que si il y a des des messages qui
sont illicites parce qu'ils sont
porteurs de violence de haine de
cyberhcèlement et cetera c'est la faute
des auteur et ça n'est pas la faute de
la plateforme et bien en européen
l'année dernière quand la France
présidait l'Union EUR n nous avons dit
stop et nous avons dit que les
plateformes elles doivent exercer ou
avoir une responsabilité vis-à-vis de
l'impact qu'elles ont sur la société et
depuis quelques semaines depuis le 25
août pour les plus grandes d'entre elles
de nouvelles obligations s'imposent à
ell quel que soit le lieu où elles sont
implantées en Europe elles doivent dés
obligation en terme de régulation doent
désormais elles doivent désormais
retirer les contenus les messages à
caractère illicite qui leur sont signalé
soit par les utilisateurs soit par des
associations comme il enfant soit par
les autorités elles doivent partager
leurs données avec des chercheurs elles
doivent faire auditer leurs algorithmes
elles doivent s'abstenir de faire de la
publicité sur les mineurs et puis il y a
une nouvelle règle règle qui est très
importante c'est qu'elles doivent
analyser et
corriger le risque qu'elles font peser
sur la santé de leurs utilisateurs on
pense à l'addiction chez les plus jeunes
sur la le cours CIVI on pense à la
propagation de fausses nouvelles et sur
la sécurité publique et là on pense au
dévoiement des réseaux sociaux notamment
pendant la période des violences
urbaines du début du mois de juillet et
ça c'est très important parce que pour
la première fois dans l'histoire du
monde ces plateformes ont une
responsabilité non pas vis-à-vis des
messages uniquement et et leur
obligation de retrait mais aussi
vis-à-vis de l'impact que leurs
algorithmes que leur fonctionnement même
va avoir sur la société alors ce
règlement est en train en vigueur la
question en réalité la seule question
c'est est-ce qui va pouvoir être
appliqué est-ce que les
sanctions la Commission européenne que
la Commission européenne va pouvoir
prononcer à l'encontre de ces PL parce
que la carotte c'est l'accès plein et
entier au marché
européen et le bâon c'est la sanction 6
% du chiffre d'affaires mondial
c'est-à-dire pour une entreprise comme
Twitter à peu près 300 millions d'euros
pour une entreprise comme TikTok à peu
près 600 millions d'euros d'amende
potentielle et en cas de manquement
répété à ces obligations nouvelles le
bâton peut aller jusqu'à l'exclusion
jusqu'au bannissement de l'Union on peut
espérer qu'à l'avenir mais c'est vrai
que ça n'est pas encore possible la
Commission européenne puisse exercer
l'une des prérogatives que lui donne ce
règlement et qui est très importante
c'est dans l'article 36 de ce règlement
il y a une possibilité qui est donnée à
la
commission
d'exiger en cas de crise grave des
plateformes qu'elle modifient
profondément le fond fonctionnement de
leurs algorithmes pour éviter les
troubles à l'ordre public à la santé
publique et cetera autrement dit dans
une situation comme celle qu'on a connu
ces derniers jours ouais où l'on voit
proliférer sur les réseaux sociaux des
contenus illicites euh d'apologie du
terrorisme de violences manifestes qui
portent atteinte à la dignité ou à
l'intégrité des personnes on peut très
bien imaginer que la commission mais
effectivement ça sera pas avant février
2024 puisse exiger des plateformes
qu'elle déviralise
qu'elle invisibilise ces contenus-là euh
le temps évidemment de pouvoir les
traiter et vous êes d'accord que là il y
a un problème de aussi de temporalité
parce qu'on sait très bien que la
viralité on l'a vu aussi dans le
documentaire d'une fausse information
euh le temps qu'on réagisse elle a déjà
été euh partagée des millions de fois
donc s'il faut attendre février 2024
pour lutter contre la désinformation
mais d'un autre côté l'Europe est la
première démocratie du monde à avoir
imposé de telles règles aux géants du
numérique et le monde entier est en
train de regarder si ce règlement va
pouvoir être appliqué pour peut-être
s'en inspirer ouais et j'ai vu quelque
part vous aviez particulièrement dans le
collimateur x Twitter racheté par Elon
Musk concernant le le conflit entre
Israël et et le Hamas hein que vous avez
évoqué vous aussi d's ce moment il y a
déjà trois enquêtes je précise en
attendant que la Commission puisse
déclencher son mécanisme de crise elle a
en attendant déclenché trois enquêtes
sur Twitter sur instag sur Facebook et
sur TikTok et elle a aussi invité les
États-membres dont la France fait partie
à faire REM à lui faire remonter euh les
constats de contenu qui seraient
contraire au droit français mais qui ne
seraient pas retiré et je vais moi-même
réunir dans quelques jours un certain
nombre d'associations et
d'administrations qui participent à la
détection de ces contenus illicites al
leur signalement à à ces grandes
plateformes pour faire un état des lieux
avec elles de tout ce qui s'est passé
depuis 15 jours pour pouvoir ensuite sur
la base de ce constat quelle plateforme
a joué le jeu à quelle vitesse ou non
transférer le tout à la Commission
européenne pour alimenter ces enquêtes
c'est le même état d'esprit il s'agit là
aussi de d'inverser le rapport de force
oui c'est c'est la continuité du travail
engagé au niveau européen mais également
en France avec un certain nombre
d'initiatives qui ont été prises ces
dernières années pour euh qu'on puisse
établir un ordre public en ligne pour
que les droits et les devoirs soient
respectés pour mettre fin à à la loi du
plus fort là j'ai la liste sous les yeux
des mesures qui son on va pas toutes les
citer il y en a peut-être une ou deux
que vous souhaitez mettre en avant et
qui sont spécifiques à la France par
rapport à ce qui est la législation
européenne bien sûr et je précise que la
législation européenne ce règlement dont
on vient de parler il s'applique dans
tous les étatsmembres c'est ça qui fait
sa force d'ailleurs sans qu'il ne soit
besoin de le transposer il faut
simplement ajouter au niveau national au
niveau au niveau national fallait juste
établir les responsabilités des
autorités ouais il vont faire appliquer
le le le DSA dans le texte de loi on les
désigne et puis en plus on
prend autorité de régulation
communication électronique et puis
l'arcom l'Autorité de régulation de
communication audiovisuelle que vous
responsabilz bien sûr qui va être le
point de contact pour la
commissionou lorsque la commission aura
besoin de savoir si oui ou non au regard
de la loi française ces plateformes se
comportent bien et bien c'est l'arcom
qui R Gera la la Commission et qui
participera notamment à ce travail
d'enquête et aux sanctions éventuelles
qui pourront en découler ensuite dans le
projet de loi on a on a ajouté quelques
mesures qui sont inspirées de notamment
travaux parlementaires de ces dernières
années pour répondre à des inquiétudes
voire même à des souffrances que
ressentent nos concitoyens sur Internet
et qui finissent par saper ouais à juste
titre leur confiance dans le numérique
c'est d'abord le filtre antiarnaque
c'était une promesse présidentielle ce
sera un rempart contre les campagnes de
SMS et de melfoduleux on a tous reçu ces
faux SMS du compte personnel de
formation on en reçoit encore on a tous
hésité à cliquer parfois on a cliqué et
ce sont 18 millions de Français dans
notre pays qui ont été victime de ce
type de manœuvre euh frauduleuse
deuxième mesure
peut-êtreul la deuxième mesure c'est la
peine de bannissement des réseaux
sociaux c'est quelque chose de très
nouveau dans notre droit qui va
permettre au juges de
décider de suspendre la participation à
un réseau social d'une personne
condamnée pour des faits de violence ou
de de ha suspendre ou bannir des réseaux
sociaux oui c'est la même chose pendant
6 mois suspendre ou bannir pendant 6
mois sur le sujet précédent parce que
c'est vrai que ça c'est c'est soulevé
dans ce film hein sous le couvert de
l'anonymat effectivement on peut faire
estut-ê important Rapp a pas
d'anony attendez on va laisser passer
parler sur le sujet précédent ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre et en résumer que
ce soit sur la question de l'accès de
nos enfants à des contenus réservés aux
adultes et à la pornographie en
particulier ou leur accès aux réseaux
sociaux ou leur accès en réalité à de
nombreux contenus qui sont sur Internet
la mre des batailles qui n'est pas une
bataille technique mais une bataille
juridique que nous qui qui est une
bataille très dure parce qu'évidemment
nous avons contre nous des vents
contraires plus puiss et des puissances
de l'argent qui bataille et qui milite
pour nous empêcher d'y parvenir c'est la
vérification
d'âge notre objectif prioritaire c'est
de l'imposer au site pornographique mais
c'est une bataille juridique épique un
combat dans laquelle dans lequel la
France est aux avant-postes et prend
tous les risques mais ensuite viendront
d'autres combats pour que la
vérification d'âge se généralise partout
et temps sur l'anony Oui l'anonymat
n'existe Paron dit bah finalement il y a
qu'à empêcher l'anonymat et puis on va
peut-être régler un certain nombre de
problèmes peut-être un peu naïvement
sans doute un peu naïvement je le
l'anonyat n'existe pas sur Internet
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure les
plateforme ont l'obligation de conserver
certaines de vos données pour pouvoir
répondre aux réquisitions des forces de
l'ordre et de l'autorité judiciaire
quand vous prenez l'affaire Mila quand
vous prenez l'affaire osi quand vous la
prenez l'affaire de Edie de dans les
trois cas des personnalités des des
jeunes femmes des jeunes hommes qui sont
des personnalités ou des artistes qui se
sont fait cyberhcelé et bien leurs
cyberhceleurs sont vu
euh pron ont vu prononcer à leur
encontre des peines de prison ferme dans
le cas des émeutes et des violences
urbaines du début de mois du mois de
juillet vous avez des dizaines de
condamnations à des peines de prison
ferme qui ont été prononcé à l'encontre
d'individus qui derrière leur écran ont
commis des délits de propagation de la
haine et de la violence en ligne sans
jamais mettre un pied dehors pourquoi et
bien parce que les enquêteurs sur
réquisition des procureur et de la
justice sont allés chercher
ces délinquants jusque chez eux pour
pouvoir les traduire devant la justice
et pour que la justice puisse prononcer
à leur rencontre des condamnations nul
ne peut impunément propager la haine et
la violence en ligne on peut toujours
vous retrouver lorsque vous commettez de
teles délit alors ça prend plus ou moins
de temps la justice a été pendant
longtemps paralysée mais je rappelle
qu'avec la loi de programmation de la
justice nous allons recruter plus de
personnel en 5 ans que la justice n'en a
recruté en 20 ans oui que avec la loi de
programmation de ministè so peutêtre
plus spécialisé dans ce domaine donc il
n'y a pas d'adonyat sur sur Internet et
et et et pour pour pour peu qu'on en ait
les moyens on retrouve toujours les
autres il faut que chacun prenne
conscience de ce que c'est que le droit
et le devoir de chacun sur internet
qu'il faut que chacun ait bien
conscience qu'on est en train
d'accroître considérablement la pression
qui est sur les plateformes et je crois
qu'il faut que chacun adopte un réflexe
civique c'est que lorsque l'on est
victime mais même lorsque l'on est
témoin de violence et de haine sur
internet il y a une chose à faire c'est
de signaler signaler ça veut dire
cliquer sur le petit bouton en haut à
droite euh de du contenu du message de
de la vidéo euh pour signaler qu'il y a
probablement un contenu illicite c'est
la seule manière d'activer la la
responsabilité des plateformes et euh et
c'est et c'est donc un véritable acte
euh civique lorsque euh vous êtes
témoins ou victime de cyberharcèlement
et de cyberharcèlement scolaire Vous
signalez à la plateforme et ensuite vous
contactez le 3018 c'est-à-dire la la la
outline qui est un un numéro de
téléphone mais aussi une application qui
est opérée par l'association i-enfance
et je le dis et dites-le autour de vous
parce que dans bien des cas que nous
avons connu ces derniers mois tragique
euh où des enfants ont même fini par se
donner la mort oui et bien un deux
enfant se donne la mort suite à un
harcèlement scolaire aujourd'hui en
France il faut que nos auditeurs il faut
que nos auditeurs sachent que la
responsabilité des plateformes qui
contribue à la diffusion à la
prolifération des contenus de
cyberhcèlement scolaire ne peut-être
engagé que si ces contenus leurt été
signalés donc il convient de signaler
massivement les contenus illicites que
vous voyez transiter sur mais c'est très
concret